but then also every once in a while like
certain cities just suck for comedy oh
tell us Miami I've heard Miami is the
worst Miami is tough you want like
working class like Orlando or Tampa
people you don't want Miami where they
like they're vapid they suck that's what
big J oakerson said he said Ohio is the
best place to do comedy Ohio's good
Columbus is great Cleveland's great uh
Cincinnati yeah they're they're like
real people that's you want people with
like jobs who have to think I mean Miami
people it's like they post pictures of
their ass for like a living yeah they
don't want to laugh they don't that's
not like a comedy crowd yeah they're
type people that would go to a show and
get real pissed off they got made fun of
if was doing crowd work yeah like I
don't want to expose myself to that that
would really hurt my Instagram don't
yeah don't make fun of my plastic
surgery spend a lot of money on this